[Música]
bastante preocupado com meu pai época da
geração manda no diz não saber um
quintal vivem não era vitória sobe qat
espírita com pneumonia e é onde se
prepara pra chamar o médico fica na rua
não pode não ser já um choque em casa
jogando no código de hoje subindo apoia
bom segunda-feira uma tristeza resolveu
ela é essa mas não fazem nada semana
inteira disse que não havia criança
grande número e chip eletrônico carro
contava mais cedo que o apresentador do
globo rural lutava vai trabalhar sempre
disse sem reclamar joga bola vamos só
ap/pa fábrica de manu já bo kyung do ppm
é mas fiquei de pé na hora do gol do
pelé é o mesmo que negue teto do cheque
no caneco olha na câmara responsável a
mãe uma conta deixava de cativos e
jogava no twitter após a convivência com
os amigos cup o carácter que possa se
pode também né descobrir porque pode não
bater em enquete que se tinha era
capelão judiação tabela dá pela tap do
canecão eu podia brincar eu joguei bem e
me representou procurava em que ele não
encontrava ninguém não
palavra de conforto ericsson mitos que a
falta do mundo em são paulo mas acabou o
namoro na praça judia namoro de wifi de
falar e escrever mas isso é tudo no
original do rg e ademais de kasai eles
usam celular de mais sou capaz de
provocar a multidão saudade da infância
vivida por mim é um tempo atrás os
tempos bombagem que é assim
trago chegava da escola e ia pra tv
livrar depois da tv globo que eu ia
lançar a infância de hoje está pesa 1
não sai não sai de perto de 600 roubados
a goiaba do pé da vizinha mas não sabia
mas brincadeira preferida na rua apertar
a campainha e juntava toda a galera mas
é da turma se fundia se entregasse a
galera apanhava conduto do brasil ali na
esquina mas que cita um não
hoje não tem isso não ninguém trata mas
não vai preso mesmo vagabundo ladrão as
crianças já não brincam de verdade só
que a fgf estagnou hatzaki verdade ele
foi só tenho saudade pois é né
o correio com ele batia cabeça no tempo
pi mas o meu amigo filme meu mundo é que
o dedicado em um mesmo ambiente ele
parou me olhou sorriu como era o
primeiro jato então emitimos passada foi
a mais e mesmo dizendo que estava no
trio pegou seus livros e não ficar de
olho nisso mil
um dia uma folha já é mas foi caiu 10
anos é outra joga na bola hoje em dia a
criança só quer saber do seu perfil
essas crianças de hoje só fogem da luta
no 4 está em liberdade perdeu a infância
só quero acabar perdendo seu tempo o seu
desapego é na próxima etapa de pula-pula
ninguém me segura briga até na chuva da
memória do nosso rio chega sujo da rua
esse foi o mesmo tempo vou brincar na
lama que tem uma vida santa emília que
não adianta maloqueiro era muito
comemora nesta madrugada a mínima na
verdade era somente o cinema e pega no
flagra minha vida fica twitter foto da
época do penta podia ver a alemanha era
nove anos o jogador era poeta base em
uma chapa quente jogador de futebol era
o sonho de muita gente essa gente
dinheiro nem o brasil era imbatível mas
não vejo nenhum piloto aquilo fazia
tempo que não existiu no brasil até o
fim uma prova chamada corrupção e da
rocha fez de conta que meu pai é
calejado não tinha tiroteio maneira
descarada chute no japão acabou por cair
no choro mas saí do jogo nem pensa em
ficar nas ruas mais bela jogada o xodó
só tenha feito piló
com o pt com a dora a aventureira mano
parpa ii foi [ __ ]
os tempos quando a gente quer se atracam
mal chega da escola e ia pra tv ligar
depois da tv globo
aí eu não reclamei do que sou o que sou
não antecipei farc junto foi bom mesmo e
não me arrependo de nada que fiz não me
arrependo não visitou então uso ela fica
louca só aí já uma coleção que tem
moleque por meio deste réptil falei da
minha infância que foi o café com pão e
se você gostou desta paróquia não
esquece de clicarem gostei aqui tá muita
gente sai antes de clicar gostei não
esquece clube gostei que deu muito
trabalho a fazer se inscreve no canal só
nunca perde vídeo novo e minhas redes
sociais que quiserem seguir essa daqui
essa paróquia foi produzido pela galera
do villa cine fala andré é isso aí mano
aqui andré loureiro eo marcelo
infelizmente não pôde estar aqui no
vídeo mas pra quem curte a sua paródia
nós somos o villa assim e quem quiser
entrar em contato com a gente em nossas
redes sociais nosso canal vai estar na
descrição então dá um só vi lá se você
quiser fazer um trabalho é só dar um
toque e cut porque do trabalho pra
caramba fazer para o gent valeu
exatamente então segue lá os caras só
podem largar meu boy foi ele que fizeram
com que assistiu e virar muitas
paróquias usei para frente e não esquece
que de 2 de dezembro tem o dvd no
gerenciar ena parla no rio de janeiro e
não comprou seu ingresso ainda vamos
ingresso quem vai gravar um especial a
vocês aqui tem internet
muito obrigado filipe castanheira por
ter participado meu amigo junto com
cielo obrigado por ter participado canal
dele na descrição do vídeo tamo junto
beijam
falei fui gostei é nóis compartilha a
galera e mostra no zap